I read somewhere back then some of the
special effects were simpler than maybe
they are now so the the Jedi mind
control when you can move objects
explain how they did well first of all
George called Star Wars the most
expensive low-budget movie ever made it
was every penny had to go up on the
screen and the ingenuity was fantastic
so for instance when I was hanging
upside down in the wampa cave they'd
have fishing wire attached to it and
pulled it out of my hand and then just
reversed the film so it's very simple
but I mean the the ingenuity is
tremendous now they CGI and spend way
too much money
let me see if we can recreate it in a
very low-tech way I'm going okay
so if I give you know if you move that
like you do all right no no you're good
in orange
well maybe a better movement further
Brigades my aim is off so you can if you
could try to get just in that general
vicinity so hang on wait wait wait wait
wait wait so we've got to look
astonished this little make sense we've
got to look astonished when Mark is
holding in the orange and then slowly
back to nothing as the orange lands okay
okay
okay so we all set
okay okay I think was that good okay
okay yeah let's watch back let's watch
back you okay
you